Gary it is so awesome to have you on
marietv thank you so much making the
time to do this thanks for having me
let's start off what is Jab Jab Jab
right hook mean I realized hump social
mean it reminds me of a boxing people
think it's this one thing but it's very
detailed yeah
then Jab Jab Jab right hook is actually
what I do give give give and then ask
and so if you're always throwing right
hooks people duck right they know what's
coming right this is my formula this is
why I have success I want to guilt
people into buying my things what do you
think are some of the the big major
mistakes you know in the context of jab
jab jab that we're all making with
social media how are we getting it wrong
the real answer is that everybody's so
hungry to get to the right hook by my
book you know by my product go to my
conference a wine everybody so
everybody's putting effort into their
right hooks 99% of people are not
putting any time or effort into their
jabs you're putting so much effort into
your jabs this is your jab totally
you're putting so much effort nobody
puts effort into their jabs I do
it's why I send people free stuff it's
why I pick up the phone and call people
and scare them it's why and the one
thing people want is your time and
effort yeah I need it too like I needed
this book for myself as much as anything
else yeah so just and I really wanted to
empower people 'ti this isn't this isn't
a rant this is a textbook content versus
context which is a big theme in this
book yes that's not you know everybody
thinks about content what are they gonna
say nobody's paying attention to the
context of the platform
I just ranted on that nobody's sitting
there and saying wait a minute animated
gifs work on tumblr why am I gonna put
you know they make and listen it's
bandwidth right it's bandwidth you take
one picture and you want to put it on
Facebook Twitter Tumblr Pinterest
because everybody thinks of social
networks as distribution channels to
bring you somewhere else yeah I think of
them as places to natively tell stories
do you suggest someone pick one platform
and get good and dominate it and then
stack on top of it a hell of a lot
better than [ __ ] I'm not doing anything
right yes that's the alternative great
I'd also like to ask them to audit what
they do for a living or recreationally
and try to find another 90 minutes that
they're standing on dumb [ __ ] and
planning to have a second platform
because this will actually work
absolutely and you actually you
mentioned something else I want to ask
you about which I think your perspective
on this topic is so refreshing when it
comes to haters or criticism either of
that I know you had a little short piece
and I don't know if it was ink or for
ink can you share that because I think
it's so friggin useful
I really respect my haters yeah I
totally know [ __ ] respect them
because it's how they feel now it takes
me times sometimes to dig in and to are
they unhappy people is there other
things going on you know did I do
something wrong by accident because I
never have that intent but if somebody
thinks you stink that means you're doing
a bad job communicating to them of what
your value proposition is when I read
the piece that you wrote again it was a
little short piece and it was about
respecting your haters and say you know
what if you actually listen to them and
say hey well what can I do better and
have a conversation it I actually found
it really really refreshing I have
incredible relationships in my life and
they're all predicated on communication
yeah if you want to have a relationship
with your audience you have to
communicate with them Gary thank you so
much for making the time especially
during the book launch and it drops
today which is fantastic
I really appreciate you being here